dans la campagne derrière nous
retrouvons pauline et jean-françois dans
le nouveau laboratoire de fabrication
des forêts stewart est en train de
préparer le premier alors du coup le
praliné que c'est un mélange d'amandes
de noisettes
ils ont grillé avec du sucre et mélanger
à du chocolat dakar
[Musique]
alors on y va chauffer à 150 degrés le
sucre est enfin prêt à être travaillés
et ses marques qui s'y attelle pendant
que jean-françois s'occupe du fourrage
au praliné
celui ci doit être mal accès de manière
continue sur une table chauffée à 75°
ont remué d'aller montrer moins un peu
la technique
ces énergies il ya quelque chose à faire
c'est un vous vite quoi je voulais voilà
oui on échange nos outils voilà alors
jeu rapide
il faut à
il faut vraiment avoir une rapidité
d'exécution assez chaud la seule chose
c'est chaud effectivement
juste à côté le sucre de marque est
enfin prêt pour la prochaine étape
[Musique]
ça passe le battage du sucre car il va
consister à faire pénétrer l'air à
l'intérieur de la masse de sucre
d'autres sortent d'obtenir le satiné du
bonbon fini voilà donc les reconnaître
hélas la texture et la couleur change
nous on est quand même très attachés à
garder cette tradition de fabriquer de
cette façon là ça devient jolie mia l'on
voit bien à ce qui apparaît très très
joli et voit la marque va maintenant
former un coup c'est un de sucre battue
qu'il va percer pour éviter une bulle
d'air mais là à ma chère pauline nous
allons être obligés de faire quick parce
que nous allons mettre le praliné à
l'intérieur et là je te la braise
secrète
donc je m'aime selon le cas ce que
cachent les jeunes dit rien bon ça y est
l'étape secrète est passé je peux vous
remonterez maintenant comment on
travaille donc là on arrivait sur une
étape pour fait on a un gros beauf ont
fait ça c'est ce que vous vous êtes à
l'heure donc là on voit bien qu'on a un
boudin rempli en fait donc oui tout à
fait et vous aller presser avec cette
machine pour faire les bons vont
finalement et sa machine là elle et elle
est ancienne
on est toujours sur la presse original
d'accord parce que george forrest a mis
au point vraiment tout le processus
non seulement la recette mélamine
matériel aussi or au point et ouest
pourrait selon moi sur cette machine oui
comme ça et on appuie bien fort et puis
voilà
neuf mille favelas tout le monde
d'accord et je vais pas me couper la
voie là on les envoie sa côte est et
voilà je vous laisse pas toujours à son
ton diplôme de foresti noz j'aime bien
ton ne fait à chaque fois j'ai toujours
le diplôme à la fin si tu veux bien je
vais te demander de les séparer
tous les bobos à la main tous les bons
on embauche et donc ben voilà bon ben
alors je n'ai pas le choix je dois y
aller j'y allais boulodrome attend donc
moi je vous laisse ici je vais aller
d'ailleurs en peluche et une au passage
et puis bah à bientôt dans une prochaine
aventure gourmande du coup au boulot